poet Strasburg she was transformed by
thousands of young people from all over
the continent for the eyes the European
youth event it was a crucible fit to
burst of ideas shows debates and demands
for solutions to the problems of the day
you have the opportunity to tell us
which kind of Europe you really want
that they did a Europe without chronic
use unemployment for a start as if
people study hard without getting the
job that scares me this is the question
also for the politicians how they want
to figure them celebrity appearances
included Dennis will quake a the
Sakharov Prize winner and the pioneering
Congolese search and helping the victims
of rape and samantha cristoforetti an
astronaut with European Space Agency the
future of Europe together we could make
a change
was the idea of driving debates on
everything from space and innovation to
climate change sustainability democracy
needs to come together and share those
and try and shape Europe and to be the
place that we want it to be is really
important I expect a lot of
contributions towards EU I gender from
the young people and that you officials
will hear them entertainment was never
far off with musicians and artists
performing in the name of solidarity
which they feel even if many believe
their elders don't it doesn't end here
the ideas and initiatives incubated at
the eye are sent to various
parliamentary committees for debate with
the young originators during the coming
months